hey guys it is August tonight or no
man's sky day if you prefer and here's a
bunch again we use the sup 2k released a
new trailer for the Bioshock remaster
that's arriving in the Bioshock
collection the trailer doesn't specify
what platform the footage was captured
on but in any case to case said that all
games in the collection run at 1080p and
up to 60 frames per second you can check
out how much better the 2007 title looks
after its makeover in the full video on
site as narrated by Andrew Ryan of
course the collection which includes
remasters the bioshock bioshock two and
bioshock infinite for consoles plus or
single-player dlc is you out on sep
tember 13 for ps4 xbox one and pc
another update from pokemon go has come
out and here are the changes the game
has added to its collection of warning
notifications and will now remind you
not to play the game while driving a car
you can also now change your nickname
one time and the nearby feature has been
replaced by a sightings feature which
tells you what creatures are in the area
Pokemon will remain in your sightings
tab as you get closer and disappear if
you move further away the patch notes
also revealed that improvements have
been made to the accuracy of a curveball
throw and a number of bug fixes have
been implemented finally I've got some
no man's sky news for you here's the
latest on its frame rate the game
targets 30 frames per second on ps4 but
digital foundry has discovered that this
does dip to 13 frames per second in one
sequence where the game engine is
dressed specifically this happened after
landing on a planet and then immediately
boosting across the surface that said
digital foundry has revealed there is a
workaround explaining once you double
back on yourself with a full 180 turn or
even slow down suddenly we're back to an
even 30 frames per second again from
here the framerate issues disappear once
you start moving again the report
suspects the drops may be due to the
game's use of procedurally generated
worlds where everything has to be
calculated ad hoc
without loading times on the whole
digital foundry reported that no man's
sky generally retains 30 frames per
second world throughout the game be sure
to stop by games flat for stories on
battlefield one and titanfall 2 and I'll
catch you with much more news tomorrow